ADAM POWELL: Hello, everyone,
and welcome to Fragment Tricks.
Today we're going to be talking
about a few effective patterns
for using the fragment
APIs in your apps.
Now, some of these
are going to BE--
they may seem a
little bit basic,
but they're also things that
are going to help you build apps
in a way that factors your
code effectively, encapsulates
things, and makes sure that
you can keep your code clean.
GEORGE MOUNT: Stupid
fragment tricks.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah.
GEORGE MOUNT: Stupid
fragment tricks.
ADAM POWELL: Anyway,
so let's go in
and start with a
little bit of history
behind this, which kind of
helps understand where some
of the fragment APIs came from.
So as we started moving
into large screen
devices in the honeycomb
era, we started
realizing that there are
a few specific patterns
in the way that some
apps are put together,
especially apps of the time.
You've got one area that's
devoted to your navigation,
and you've got another area
that's devoted to content.
And when you put these
two things together,
you can imagine
on a small screen
device you might see the
navigation as one screen
that advances to
a content screen,
and when you're on a
larger screen device
you're able to show the
same things side by side.
So we had this question of
how do you write an app that
works seamlessly across both?
So the fragment APIs were born.
It was something that you could
use to factor out your activity
components into
two separate pieces
that you could show differently
based on different device
configurations.
Now this works really well for
some applications, like Gmail,
but your app
probably isn't Gmail.
If you followed the
development of app design
over the past several
years, you realize
that this sort of
pattern just doesn't
fit for a lot of things.
However, it's still extremely
useful for representing
your application as a
series of destinations.
So even on a small
screen device,
you might have an app that
looks something like this.
We've got our little
application that--
where you can order
some micro kitchen
snacks around the Google campus.
And for each one
of these screens,
you can perform a
replace transaction
to replace the destination
that you were looking
at previously with the new one.
Replace transaction will remove
any fragment in the container
and then add the new fragment.
So the nice thing
about this is that you
can place these particular
transactions on the back stack,
and we'll go ahead and handle
that back navigation for you.
Now the nice thing about this is
that the content and navigation
pane separation isn't limited
to just large screens.
This can really help to
keep your chrome stable
in your application.
So any time that you have
things like bars, net drawers,
bottom navigation bars,
any of these things
that you want to keep
stable and perform
some consistent animations
from one screen to another,
this really lets you
do it in a way that
is really difficult to
accomplish with the activity
to activity transitions,
where you can't preserve
that kind of
continuity in your UI
as you navigate deeper
in your app's hierarchy.
GEORGE MOUNT: Let's talk
a little navigation flows.
Now, when I talk about
navigation flows,
I'm talking about those
step-by-step flows
that you have in
your application.
So when you have a checkout or
a sign up or a setup wizard,
the users are going
to go step by step
through their
navigation, and then they
might want to wander back
using the back button
and then go forward again.
And then when
they're all done, you
want to be all done with that.
You don't want
that one user to be
able to go back through
the checkout process again
with the back button.
That would kind of
suck, wouldn't it?
So we're going to
here focus on our app,
the Micro Kitchen
app, which we've
been trying to sell
to the Googlers
to sell them the free
micro kitchen snacks.
ADAM POWELL: It hasn't
been working very well
GEORGE MOUNT: It has not.
But we know we have
new customers coming
in the summer--
interns-- so we're
pretty sure that they
will partake in our great
free micro kitchen service.
And when the user
comes in, they're
going to click on the check
out-- on the cart button.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to remove the
little cart at the bottom,
that little fragment
there, and then we're
also going to move that big--
replace that big fragment at
the top with our new fragment,
that we're going to label cart.
Not the fragment,
but we're going
to label the state "Cart."
And I'm going to talk
about that a little bit
later, why we're giving it
a name on the back stack.
And then when they
hit check out,
they can then choose the
address they want to ship to,
and we're just going to
replace that fragment
with their address
selection one.
And they can choose
payment then,
and we replace it again
with a payment fragment.
And again, it's
at the back stack.
And this time, we don't need a
name for this back stack state.
Because we don't need--
well, we'll talk about it.
Well they can go back through
the back stack if they want.
They can navigate back and
choose a different address
if they want by hitting
the back button.
And as developers, we don't
have to do any other work.
Back stack just pops
that fragment right back
into our state, and it's great.
And then the user can go back
through, choose a payment,
and then confirm the purchase.
Now here, in the
confirm purchase screen,
we're to do a couple
of things all at once.
We're going to do
a pop back stack,
all the way back to
that original cart state
that we said.
And because we passed
the inclusive flag there,
now it pops that
cart state also.
And it'll go all the way
back, pop all the states back,
and then, at the same time,
we add this new transaction,
which will replace that state
with our thank you page.
Because we want to thank
them for giving them--
for giving us all their money.
It's pretty good, I mean,
we need to thank them
for giving us all their money.
Now on this one, we have
a little different thing
going on.
The OK button doesn't just
create a new transaction,
it's going to pop a
back stack as well.
Now, no matter what the
user does, it's going to--
the user's going to
do the right thing.
They're not going to add
a new transaction-- add
to that state.
We don't want to
have that thank you
page come back again if
they pop the back stack.
So it's going to come
right back to where they
can buy more stuff from us.
So you can see some of the keys
here to back stack management.
Always maintain your
back stack going forward.
It's so much easier to
manage your back stack
if you choose the
direction your user is
going to go on the back stack
as you navigate forward.
Don't, at the time the user
presses the back button,
choose what they're going to do.
That's a lot harder to manage.
So to take advantage
of this kind of thing,
sometimes you need to do
some synthetic back stack
management.
That means if you
have an external link
into your application, some
kind of deep, nested thing,
they're selecting a
particular cart item.
And when they hit
the back button,
you don't want them
to go to some--
the main screen, you want
them to go into the category,
perhaps.
ADAM POWELL: Or even
from a notification.
GEORGE MOUNT: Or
from a notification,
that's a great example.
From a notification.
Or maybe a search
inside your application,
you might want to
have the same thing.
So what do we do?
Well, we just execute a
whole bunch of transactions
all at the same time.
Just build up the set for them,
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Execute them.
ADAM POWELL: Well,
hang on, George.
So if I can make
repeated transactions,
then that means that each
one of those transactions I'm
going to start and
stop those fragments
as I execute each one in turn.
So that can be really
expensive, right?
So how do I go ahead and
maintain that back stack state
while still not doing a whole
lot of really heavyweight work
as I start and stop each one of
those fragments along the way?
GEORGE MOUNT: Yeah that's
a really big problem.
Because you have to
create all those views,
tear them down again, inflation.
ADAM POWELL: Right, it seems
like a lot of unnecessary work.
GEORGE MOUNT: It is a
lot of unnecessary work.
Sorry, guys.
Well-- you want to fix that?
ADAM POWELL: Sure.
GEORGE MOUNT: All right.
Thanks, Adam.
So now we have
this new thing here
called set reordering allowed.
And what this does is it
allows all of the execution
to happen all at once, without
changing your fragment state.
And then at the very end, we
bring up all the fragments
that need to be brought up and
tear down all the fragments
that need be torn down.
And now your fragments don't
have to go through all that,
oh, I got added, I got removed,
I got added, I got removed.
So we can optimize this for you.
But you have to watch out,
because if you expected
a fragment to
exist that didn't--
that might have
been optimized out,
if you expected it to
go through its creation,
it might not have done that.
So you have to
watch out for this.
So you use this in
your applications.
It's great to use, but expect
some slightly different
behavior than before.
Now you might have seen
in our application,
that as the user clicked
through the check out screen,
it was just pop, pop, pop, pop.
Those screens changed
instantaneously,
and that's not very pleasant.
So what we can do is
we can add transitions.
The easiest ones to use
are the basic transitions
that come with fragments,
and there are three options.
And this is done
on the transaction,
you call set.Transition,
and the basic transitions
are fade, open, and close.
And from this it's really
hard to see the differences,
but you can see the fade
has just a simple crossfade,
and the open and close
also have a fade and zoom.
So play with it a
little bit, see what
works well in your application.
See what you like best.
It provides a nice, subtle
effect for your transitions.
ADAM POWELL: What if I want to
do something a little bit more
in keeping with my
own app's design?
GEORGE MOUNT: Yeah.
If you want something a
little bit more custom, then
we can use animations.
Animations in this case
is the view animations
that allow you to change scale,
rotation, translation, alpha,
so fading.
So you can set those four--
and this is only on
support library--
you can set those on
the view coming in,
the fragment coming
in, a separate one
for the fragment being popped--
sorry, being removed--
and also the same things
for the pop as well.
The ones that are being
added and removed.
So you can have different
animations for each of those,
and you can an effect like
this, which is very nice.
A slide effect, which you
couldn't do with the basic
animations-- basic transitions.
Now, if you're working with
the framework fragments,
you can do the same
things with animators.
But they provide
even more benefit,
because now you can animate
any property on the view.
That means you can have some
really custom animations,
whatever you want to do.
It's great.
And what's better
is now you can also
do that in the support library.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
GEORGE MOUNT: Transition style
is also added for the framework
so that you can do this--
set your animators in a style.
Now, a lot of you have been
using the activity transitions,
and you want to have that
work with fragments as well.
So activity transitions
allows this great ability
to have a shared element change
from one view to another.
So in this case, from
one fragment to another.
And it works in activity
transitions from Lollipop on.
It's very useful.
And so we added the
ability to do that.
So in fragments, instead of
doing this on the transaction,
you do this on the
fragment itself.
You can set the animation--
the transition to do
on the views that are coming in,
and this is for all the views
that are not the SharedElement.
So that's the EnterTransition.
And the
SharedElementEnterTransition,
this is the one you do on
the view that is moving.
This is our SharedElement,
in this case,
I don't know what it was.
The almonds, maybe.
And here this move
uses a combination
of change bounds, change
transform, and change image
transform.
Too many things to
fit on the slide,
but that's what it is here.
And then in the transaction, we
add the SharedElement itself.
And the SharedElement is the
view that's in that fragment,
and then we have a target name.
This name, this is the
SharedElement transition name,
and this is the name that you've
given the transition element
in the fragment that has
not been inflated yet.
So in this case, it's
in the my fragment
that's being pulled in.
And then, we can have our
transition, which is great,
but something's wrong.
Can you see it?
Everyone raise his
hand if you can see it.
What's the problem with this?
OK, a lot of you
can see the problem.
Right, transition's
only working one way.
It works great getting
into the detail view,
but when we come back
to that main view
with all of these other
elements, you're not seeing it,
and why is that?
Well that main view
is a recycler view,
and what's happening
is the recycler view
will lay out its views after
the set adapter call is made.
So we have to wait
for the layout call
after this set
adapter call is made.
And the transition's
coming in and said, hey,
I want the shared element.
And it's not there,
so what does it do?
It says, oh, give up.
Fade out.
And so in activity
transitions, what do we do?
Well, it's great.
We have this thing called
postponing the transaction--
postponing the transition.
So we have a
postponeEnterTransition,
and then when the
views are ready,
we call
startPostponedEnterTransition.
So it gives you all
the ability to say, OK,
just hold on a second.
Wait for my view, come on,
come on, views, come on, views.
[WHISTLES] And then when they're
all ready, then you say go.
So we want to do this
for fragments as well.
So here we go.
We can do it for fragments.
But there's one extra
thing you need to do.
You absolutely have to have
the set reordering allowed.
Because for a short time
while you're postponing
both fragments are there,
they're both active.
And that is not the
order you expect, is it?
You expected one to be removed,
and another one to be added.
So both views for both fragments
are in the created save.
So that's going to be
a little weird for you,
so we want to make sure
that you know that you're
getting into this situation.
So let's see how it's
done in our application.
In my onCreate view-- now,
you can do this anytime before
onCreate--
onCreate view.
So if you wanted to, you
could do it onCreate,
whatever you want to do.
You call
postponeEnterTransition.
Because I know at this point I
am going to do a recycler view,
and I know I need to worry
about the transitions there.
And because I love
data binding--
some of you might know
that, I love data binding--
and we have a few models here,
too, so that's good, too.
ADAM POWELL: Mhm.
GEORGE MOUNT: Thank you, Adam.
If you haven't
seen that talk, you
should go back and watch it.
We're using that.
So here I'm setting the
adapter for my recycler view.
Now I'm setting my adapter, now
I have to wait for the layout.
So I wait for the layout,
and then that listener
I call
startPostponedEnterTransition.
Now my transition is ready,
and it will just go on ahead--
and I think I skipped a slide.
[LAUGH] Oh, OK.
It works.
ADAM POWELL: All right.
So one of the other feature--
moving along to something
completely different-- one of
the other features that we get
a lot of questions
about are the set
retain instance
method on fragments.
So you retain an instance
across an activity destruction
and creation, across something
like a configuration change.
So this means that the
object instance itself
of the fragment that
you've marked this way
is transferred across
the parent recreation.
So anything that you put
there is moved along with it.
Full objects, you don't
have to serialize this
into a personable, passed
across saved instance state.
But the important thing to
remember if you're doing this
is that this doesn't happen
if the process is recreated.
Your objects aren't there.
So you need to be a little
bit careful about this.
You need to make sure
that you can still
restore from
instant state if you
have to, even though
in the common case
you still have the full
objects that you may have
created in the first place.
So this is a replacement
for the old, unretained
non-configuration instance
method that was on activity.
In fact, the same
mechanism is used
to implement the
fragments version of this.
But what's a little
bit more interesting
is that this
mechanism is right now
the backbone of am in
view model component
that we've been talking
about earlier at I/O here.
So the view models are actually
saved within a retain instance
fragment to shuffle them across
from one activity to the next.
And this just kind
of goes to show
the types of
infrastructure that you
can build on top of a
routine instance fragment.
It's something that's a little
bit on the more abstract end
of things, so we end up getting
a lot of questions about,
hey, what's this good for?
This is a pretty good example.
And just like we talked
about with view models,
it means that
there's a few things
that you really need to avoid.
In this case, don't put views
in a retain instance fragment,
unless you want to do a
lot of manual bookkeeping.
Technically, you can
kind of get away with it
if you're really careful.
Make sure that you release
all your references
and on destroy view of
that particular fragment,
so on and so forth.
But really it ends up being
best just to kind of avoid it,
and we'll get into a few more
patterns later in the talk here
around what you can do instead.
Context, specifically
activity context.
Well, we all know
why you don't want
to save an instance
of an activity longer
than the lifetime of
that activity itself.
But the thing that really
tends to catch people
is callback references.
So if you register a
listener or some sort
of a callback with a
fragment, and that fragment
is going to outlive
the container,
it's really easy to accidentally
close over that context
that you had and have
the activity still
outlast the original host.
So child fragments are
something that bit a lot
of people really
hard a few years ago,
because frankly, we had a
lot of bugs around them.
And they were created to
solve a particular problem,
and that was
dependency management
within a particular activity.
So consider this case.
You've got a fragment
that has a ViewPager.
Pretty common, right?
The ViewPager uses a
fragment pager adapter,
because that's a pretty
easy way to use a ViewPager,
and then you remove
the pager fragment.
Well, now we have a problem.
So what actually
happens in that case,
you've got all
the fragments that
were added by the PagerAdapter,
but the host fragment--
or the conceptual host
fragment in this case
that has the ViewPager--
itself was removed.
Now something has
to be in charge
of removing the
individual page fragments,
and this was something
that really kind of went
to show that a single collection
of fragments is insufficient.
In fact, when the fragment APIs
were first sort of rolling out
to a lot of internal developers
right around Honeycomb,
this was one of the first
questions that we got,
and it took us quite a while
to come back and address this.
What happens when you do
have these dependencies
in between fragments.
And part of the reason
why this was such a pain
is because we didn't have
any ordering guarantees
around Fragments being created.
And what's worse
is a lot of times
this only would come up much,
much later in the process.
Just because you added Fragments
in one particular order,
you could control
that that order
as you're running that and kind
of run the initial transactions
that builds up that state.
But when your process dies
and we restore those fragments
from instance state later,
the order of that recreation
was always undefined.
Depending on what
all may have happened
throughout the lifetime
of your activity
before, just kind of
due to some artifacts
of internal
bookkeeping, this was
something that could cause
these things to be reordered
in terms of which one
would get onCreate first,
so on and so forth.
And it made it very
difficult to reconnect
any sorts of shared state.
Now the source of
shared state is
something that's much easier
to handle with the ViewModel
system that we showed
earlier, but at the time
we really didn't have a good
solution to this problem.
So one of the other things
that was kind of a pain
is that the deferred transaction
commits that have been common
ever since we--
up until we added
the commit now method
on Fragment transaction--
the nice thing
and the reason why
this was done in the first place
was to avoid reentering calls.
You didn't have to worry about
one particular transaction
being half executed and then
starting another transaction
as a result of it.
But this really did
have a cost, and I
think that if you're
in this room right now,
you've probably experienced
some of the costs of this.
Raise your hand if you called
executePendingTransactions
to fix a bug.
Yeah, that's a lot of hands.
So this is one of
those things that
ends up being really kind
of difficult to work with.
So child fragments as
dependencies work out
really well, because
they solve a lot
of these particular issues.
It's a separate
Fragment manager,
so you don't get the re-entrant
cases no matter what.
If you go ahead and use commit
now on a bunch of these things,
you don't have to
worry about your parent
being in a potentially
inconsistent state
as you do this, because
you're all working
within your own local unit.
So all of these things
are added and removed
as a unit, which means that it
solves that ViewPager problem.
It means that if you remove
the containing fragment,
then you don't have to care
about the implementation
details of that fragment.
Well, this kind
of seems like one
of those duh things
in hindsight,
and it's all guaranteed
to be restored after I
called the super.onCreate.
This is also important
because now you
can rely on when these things
have actually been restored.
You don't have to worry
about these ordering things
that are out of your control.
But perhaps most importantly,
the implementation details
again don't leak into your
surrounding containers.
So in conclusion,
many of you may
have run into a lot
of particular issues
around child fragments.
Please go try version 26.
We have fixed more and
more issues around this,
specifically around
inflating child fragments.
This is one of my
favorite uses of this.
We talked earlier about using
Fragments as very coarse grain
destinations within
your application.
Something that takes up an
entire UI pane of your app.
But nesting within
other Fragments,
even if you inflate them from
one of these coarser grain
navigation destinations,
it just kind of works.
You don't have to
worry about taking
care of all these other sort
of nested lifecycle issues,
and it lets you build smarter
encapsulated components I mean,
we always kind of get this
question, too: hey, do I build
[INAUDIBLE], do I
build a Fragment?
And there's been a lot of ink
spilled and keyboards smashed
making these particular
arguments online, as I'm sure--
GEORGE MOUNT: I never
know what to do with this.
ADAM POWELL: Hm?
GEORGE MOUNT: I never
know what to do, building
a ViewGroup or a Fragment.
ADAM POWELL: Right.
So--
GEORGE MOUNT: I just tell
people just use ViewGroups.
ADAM POWELL: Exactly.
So-- excuse me, Adam, you
said that crossing the streams
was bad.
So the rule of thumb for this
is essentially as follows.
Views should really only be
responsible for displaying
information and publishing
direct user interaction events.
These end up being
very low level events,
like button was clicked,
user scrolled something.
These are responsible
for drawing text
and these other
sorts of operations
that are user interaction,
whereas fragments integrate
with the surrounding
lifecycle, and they may be
aware of other app components.
This is really what gives
context to everything
that you're doing in your UI.
So you might bind
to a service, you
might be communicating
with your apps data model,
performing a database
query, so on and so forth.
So you should never use a
Fragment when a View will do,
but you also want make
sure that you're not
adding outside
dependencies to your Views.
It's definitely a
code smell if you ever
find yourself doing
something like trying
to bind to a service from
a view implementation,
or trying to make a
network call, or again,
trying to integrate
with anything
that's outside of the realm of
just that one individual view.
But that means that
there's a whole.
It means that you can't
build just something
that simple as a completely
self-contained like button
that you can just stick
right in the middle of one
of your layouts and treat
is as fire and forget.
Give it some parameters and go.
Well, this is one of the reasons
why you can inflate Fragments.
In this case, we're showing
that you can define parameters
to these that you
can place inline.
We can go ahead and inflate
arguments in a way that--
excuse me-- in a
way that allows you
to do this without
having a lot of very
heavyweight integration.
You don't have to go find
it, configure it separately,
you just do it inline.
So one of the things that made
this really difficult to do
in the past was again,
just artifact of history,
and that you couldn't actually
set Fragment arguments,
that arguments bundle
after the Fragment
had been added to
a Fragment manager.
So now we've relaxed
that, and we've
said that now
Fragment arguments can
be changed any time that
the state isn't saved,
including during inflation.
So there's this case where
after you rotate or so on and so
forth and we're reconnecting
inflated fragments, which
is, again, something that
we do automatically, then
you can run in this
case where we've already
restored that Fragment.
We're trying to hook
it back up again,
but it's already
added, which means
that you can't do what the
natural thing is, which
is to represent
all those arguments
that you may inflate as
arguments in the bundle.
So that way you have
basically a single source
of truth for all
the configuration
parameters of that Fragment.
Well, now you can.
GEORGE MOUNT: Wait a
second, wait a second here.
Go back.
Was this not a state save thing?
ADAM POWELL: Oh yeah.
Again, a bunch of people had--
I don't know where
this comes from,
but people apparently try to
commit Fragment transactions
when state's already been
saved, and they've got--
GEORGE MOUNT: Why
would they do that?
ADAM POWELL: I don't know, but--
GEORGE MOUNT: Because
they can't tell?
ADAM POWELL: That
might have been it.
Yeah, so we added a
simple getter on this one
so that you can know
when that happens.
And it also makes things
like writing lifecycle aware
components that make
sure that you don't
try to commit Fragment
transactions when it's not
valid to do so is a whole
heck of a lot easier.
Thank you.
So again, part of what
we're trying to do here
is create a much better
layered infrastructure.
We've traditionally hidden
a lot of these internals
in some of these
Android components,
such that only the internal
components are twiddling them,
which means that
as soon as you all
have a more complicated case
that you're trying to handle,
we've made it very difficult
for you to do this in the past.
So we tried to open a
lot more of those things
up, make these things
a little bit easier
to inspect from your own code,
to deal with those cases that
arise that we didn't think of.
So in this case, the pattern
that we really kind of want
to encourage is mapping
Fragment arguments
to attributes for
those UI Fragments.
Again, this gives you kind
of a single source of truth.
So let's go ahead and go
over to an example of this.
So in this case, we've got
a few nice little Kotlin
based methods that are
extensions, that make us
a little bit easier to handle.
In this case, we've got one
utility methods that is just
our withStyledAttributes here.
So, many of you have dealt with
inflating attributes for views,
and you have to get
that typed array,
you have to recycle
it afterwards.
It's really easy to just
kind of wrap these up
inside some extension functions.
Similarly, we have this
simple little thing.
Hey, is there a bundle there
for arguments already, if so,
reuse it, otherwise
create a new one.
So these are the sorts of
things that Kotlin really
adds to the Fragment API.
All the things that are
kind of a pain in the neck
to do with Fragments, you can
make some simple extensions
that were really
hard to do before.
But for example, one of my
favorite features for something
like this is to use
property delegates
to deal with
arguments, and you can
wrap even more of this stuff
and just basically treat them
as normal properties on
your Fragment objects.
So putting a bunch
of this together,
Fragments help you maintain
more of a content and chrome
separation.
They give you the ability
to keep your content pages
as fully encapsulated
items without disturbing
the rest of the UI around it.
You get richer transitions.
You get better
shared components ,
because you can reuse a lot of
these things and you don't have
to initialize all
of them separately.
And you can better
encapsulate your dependencies.
So you don't necessarily have
to leak all of these things
to the surrounding host.
And thank you very
much for coming.